>> I WONDER IF YOU CAN COMPARE
THE PATRIOT MISSILE SYSTEM TO
THE AIR DEFENSE SYSTEMS UKRAINE
IS ALREADY RELYING ON,
PARTICULARLY OLD SOVIET MADE
ONES BUT ONES SUPPLIED BY NATO
PARTNERS IN RECENT MONTHS.
IS THIS A MAJOR UPGRADE IN TERMS
OF TECHNOLOGY?
>> YES, IT IS.
ONE OF THE THINGS, JIM, IS THAT
IT JUUSES A PHASED ARRAY RADAR
THAT MEANS THE PATRIOT SYSTEM
CAN HONE IN ON A TARGET USING
MULTIPLE BEAMS WITHOUT CHANGING
THE ANTENNA CONFIGURATION, THEY
DON'T HAVE TO MOVE THE ANTENNAS,
DO ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
A LOT OF THE SYSTEMS THEY HAVE
RIGHT NOW, WHETHER THE OLD
SOVIET ERA SYSTEMS OR NEWER
SYSTEMS FROM NATO COUNTRIES,
THEY ARE BASICALLY DESIGNED IN
SOME CASES AT LEAST TO BE LESS
RELIANT ON TECHNOLOGY AND MORE
PHYSICALLY RELIANT.
SO WHAT THAT WOULD MEAN IS THOSE
SYSTEMS REQUIRE THE PHYSICAL
MOVEMENT OF ANTENNAS, THEY CAN
THEN DETERMINE WHERE THE
MISSILES ARE, SO IT'S A MUCH
MORE COMPLEX UNDERTAKING THAN
THE UKRAINIANS HAVE RIGHT NOW.
THE PATRIOT SYSTEM WILL
UNDERMINE THAT.
>> I WONDER, THIS IS A MASSIVE
AND EXPANDING RUSSIAN AIR AND
MISSILE ASSAULT ON UKRAINE, AND
PARTICULARLY THE TARGETS IN
RECENT WEEKS HAVE BEEN ON
INFRASTRUCTURE, THAT IMPACT THE
LIVES OF CIVILIANS, THAT'S
DELIBERATE HERE.
HOW MANY OF THESE SYSTEMS, GIVEN
THIS IS THE LARGEST COUNTRY IN
EUROPE, DOES UKRAINE NEED TO
MAKE A DENT IN RUSSIA'S AIR WAR?
>> THAT'S A REALLY INTERESTING
QUESTION.
GENERALLY WHAT YOU WANT TO DO,
JIM, IS IF YOU DEPLOY THE
PATRIOT SYSTEM, YOU WANT TO
DEPLOY IT TO THE AREAS YOU WANT
TO DEFEND MOST.
SO IT WOULD BE LOGICAL FOR THE
UKRAINIANS TO DEPLOY IT AROUND
KYIV, FOR EXAMPLE, AND CITIES
LIKE KDNIPRO AND KHERSON,
CERTAINLY AROUND KHARKIV, ANY OF
THE AREAS THEY WANT TO PROTECT
THEIR INFRASTRUCTURE, WHICH
GENERALLY SPEAKING COULD MEAN
THE ENTIRE COUNTRY IN THE IDEAL
WAY.
A LO OF PEOPLE COMPARE THE
PATRIOT SYSTEM TO THE IRON DOME
SYSTEM THE ISRAELIS HAVE.
IT'S BASED ON THE PATRIOT
SYSTEM, BUT ISRAEL HAS MUCH LESS
OF A SURFACE AREA TO WORRY ABOUT
THAN UKRAINE DOES.
AND IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO DEFEND
THE WHOLE COUNTRY SO YOU WANT TO
PICK THE TARGETS YOU WANT TO
PROTECT AND MAKE SURE YOU
PROTECT AIR BASES, GOVERNMENT
INSTALLATIONS AND POPULATION
CENTERS SO THAT WOULD BE WHERE
THEY DEPLOY THAT.
HOW MANY, YOU'RE PROBABLY
LOOKING SOMEWHERE BETWEEN -- IF
I WAS DOING THIS, AROUND FIVE TO
TEN BATTERIES OF THAT TYPE.
THAT WOULD BE A PRETTY BIG ORDER
AND THAT WOULD BE, YOU KNOW,
SOMEWHERE AROUND A $10 BILLION
COMMITMENT IF WE WENT TO
MAXIMIZE WITH THE PATRIOT
DEPLOYMENT.
>> AS YOU KNOW BETTER THAN ME,
WAR IS ABOUT ADJUSTMENTS, EACH
SIDE CHANGES AND ADJUSTS.
AND ONE ADJUSTMENT RUSSIA HAS
MADE IS TO BRING IN THESE
IRANIAN DRONES, AND THEY'VE HAD
DEVASTATING EFFECT ON CIVILIAN
TARGETS AND INFRASTRUCTURE IN
UKRAINE.
WOULD THE PATRIOT SYSTEM BE
EFFECTIVE AGAINST THE DRONES?
>> YES, GENERALLY SPEAKING IT
WOULD.
IT WOULD DEPEND ON THE DIFFERENT
TYPE OF PATRIOT SYSTEM, THERE
ARE DIFFERENT MODELS BUT THE
SYSTEM IS CAPABLE OF DOWNING
DRONES.
IT'S BEEN USED BY THE ISRAELIS
TO DOWN HAMAS BASED DRONES.
IT'S BEEN USED IN OTHER
CONFLICTS LIKE THE CONFLICTS IN
YEMEN.
SO IT CAN BE USED FOR THAT
PURPOSE.
OF COURSE THE HA DEES HAVE USED
UKRAINIAN DRONES AS WELL.
SO THERE IS SOME OPERATIONAL
SIGNIFICANCE HERE AND SOME
HISTORY WITH THESE TYPES OF
WEAPONS AND IT CAN BE USED IN
THAT WAY.
>> CEDRCEDRIC, THANK YOU FOR
BREAKING IT DOWN.